now uh let me just give you a brief
skeleton
um of these i'm gonna flick through
these three pages uh
i've taken a chronological approach to
organizing what you're gonna be doing
today
okay so the first question which i'm
gonna try and answer for you is
like tonight tomorrow in the weeks to
come
how do you study maths okay how do you
actually go about getting ready for it
okay because there's right ways to do it
and very unhelpful ways to do it okay
then i'm going to think a little more
long term your half yearly is going to
be coming up probably sometime next time
right and um you know it's a funny thing
right i
um i thought to myself as a student
right
i was the kind of person who was quite
okay in class or with my friends if you
ask me a question i would get it then
i'd get to the exam
and my brain would just melt down and i
would i would take forever i
wouldn't finish things there's this
thing we call exam
technique right which is that you can be
good at a subject
but then it's quite another thing to be
good at the exams for that subject right
so that's what that'll be about
and then lastly we're going to try and
think about next year you're going to
become
senior students it's going to be a big
deal and the question you guys have to
answer for yourself
is what kind of math if any
should i do next year you have some
serious choices to make
okay and the choice you do you make will
have a significant impact obviously
on how you go for the next couple years
and beyond that okay
and if we go for time what time we want
to get out of here 12 25
25 okay if we have time um i'd like to
like leave five minutes for questions as
well
all right